foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight
protesters made Global headlines with
this orange powdered protest at the
world soccer championships now boss
Barry Hearn says he will sue them and
the Eco protesters belong in jail he
joins me live
students at the UK's top university
Revolt are a debate featuring feminist
philosopher Kathleen stock but I thought
hearing opposing views was the entire
point of being at University we'll have
that debate if they allow us to the
little snowflakes plus a London theater
urges white people to stay away from the
performance exploring racial issues so
it can be free of the white gays black
people really need safe spaces like this
or is it just actually racism
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is
if it appears Morgan on says we normally
start this show I don't know by talking
about people who moan who whine who
complain about life the woke Brigade you
know the ones I'm talking about the
whining little wasterals that wreck our
ability to have fun has become
fashionable to be fragile trendy to be
traumatized as validation in being a
victim and I'm all about being a victim
by the way I'm an Arsenal fan we blew an
eight-point lead at the top of the
Premier League to give another title to
oil Rich Manchester City there they are
lift them a trophy yesterday rubbing it
squarely in my bitter and twisted face
but some hours I keep being reminded of
social media it's wrong for me to
categorize what happened to my team as
failure it was a great success
apparently if I say otherwise while I'm
demeaning the players how do we get to
this place
every day we're overwhelmed by stories
about people who are motivated by
nothing and offended by everything
but not today today I found an antidote
a Shepherd to guide us through this
Maelstrom of self-infected misery a
little ray of sunshine through the black
clouds of wokery his name is Michael
block
you may not have heard of him you
probably if you don't like golf you
definitely won't have heard of him it's
all about golf it's about a lot more
than golf Michael block is 46 years old
he's a club professional
just a journeyman Club professional he
gives golf lessons every week for about
150 bucks a time in his local Club in
California literally teaches people how
to play the game once a week he takes a
bucket of balls at himself and whacks
him around well last week he made the
cut at a major PGA Golf Tournament one
of the top four tournaments in the world
in golf
and for the first time in his life and
he found himself rubbing shoulders with
the superstars of the game he didn't
just make up the numbers
he did incredibly well and on the last
day he found himself paired with Rory
McIlroy one of the greatest players in
golf
are you serious
wow
that should be fine we're gonna have a
good time
well it was fun that every man humility
and infectious Spirit he couldn't
believe he's gonna be playing with Roy
McElroy powered him through the week and
on to that final Sunday yesterday and
the more interviews that he gave Michael
block the more that he played the more
the crowds both there and on television
fell in love with this guy he was the
Regular Joe given an extraordinary once
in a lifetime opportunity that he seized
and boy did he sees it watch what he did
yesterday
seconds ago at the 15th
fairy tale story
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean you hardly ever see that by the
way it all the bounces before he goes in
or it rolls in how often do you see a
hole in one go straight in and then the
next question how often do you see it
done by a 46 year old journeyman Club
professional in a major tournament when
he's playing marori McElroy in front of
thousands and thousands of spectators
if Michael block couldn't believe it had
gone it's because nobody else could
either this shouldn't be happening top
ranking stars go through careers without
ever doing that it's like scoring a
hat-trick at the World Cup Final in
football and in this case it was scored
by a player you've never heard of making
his first appearance well friends and
family watching his local Club where he
normally works as a golf instructor
matched out of the thousands of other
Spectators he's electrified all week and
to cap it all off
he then gave this remarkably moving
summary of the week that I think
reflected his very genuine gratitude
you said it yesterday that this was the
best week of your life what do you call
it now
thanks Amanda I appreciate you making me
cry
um
it's it's amazing uh
I'm living a dream I'm making sure that
I enjoy this moment I've learned that
after the my 46 years of life that uh
it's not going to get better than this
there's no way
no chance in hell so uh I'm gonna enjoy
this and thank you
what a guy humble funny inspirational
decent hard-working a real grafter
and how moving was that how inspiring
a normal bloke who defied ridiculous
souls to tear up a major sporting
tournament
Michael block the Rocky Balboa of golf
in this world of little whiners
we should all be more like Michael block
well I'm joined fortuitously by the
legendary Sports promoter Barry
hunterbury he came on to talk about
something else and we'll get to that in
a moment but first of all I love this
story because it's all about golf it's
not really about sport it's about life
never giving up keep trying all these
virtues which have become unfashionable
mental strength resilience
all that stuff but what's not
unfashionable is that we all love A
Cinderella Story yeah we all remember
what happened to Cinderella she went to
the ball she lost her shoe but she got
the winning prince in the end and what
Michael blocked it was so that anyone
can do it yeah you know in life in sport
you can only be the best you could be
nothing else do you feel that we're in
an era now where people just give up too
easy on everything no not necessarily I
think we're in an era of ultimate
professionalism which sometimes takes
the part of losing the personalities
that's driven out of you well I wasn't
talking about sports so much I talk
about life Society it seems to me that
your generation right would never give
an inch about anything no you came from
a Grafton generation with a grafter
mindset not for you celebrating losing
or weakness right I mean it wouldn't
cross your mind no well I think we did
come from a different time but I think
that spirit is still there somewhere out
there to be found and certain
individuals don't do anything but shock
you win a market block comes on the
scene oh goodness me never seen it
before actually we have we've seen it a
dozen times yeah and it's memories that
live with us forever and that will live
with him forever but also in a way I
think in the state that golfs in with
the live tour on the one side PGA on the
other we forgot what the game's about
it's about people like Michael well it
was interesting because uh Brooks kepka
won obviously yeah and he's a Live Tour
golfer
um Rory McIlroy was pretty good to him
actually and hugged him and
congratulations didn't say much about
Liv during this tournament it looks to
me like the beginning to calm down maybe
do a deal I think differently because I
think they will realize that this is a
horrendous accident waiting to happen
that this live tour has actually
reduced enormously the value of golf
because of oversupply in the market golf
doesn't rate particularly well on
television frankly and the live tour has
given an alternate broadcast opportunity
to other broadcasters I think they're
all really getting to realize this it's
a lot of money involved and for the
players that drawing it they've had some
big signing on fees Etc that's not
necessarily the answer because they're
suddenly realizing you can't buy history
and you can't buy special moments that
people like Michael Brooke supplied it
goes beyond the normal Realms of who's
getting a few million dollars more
let's talk about why you were due to
come on here which is this the Eco
Warriors who obviously that amongst
their many targets the just stop oil
protesters attacked the World Snooker
Championship let's take a look
terrible terrible scenes here at The
Crucible
so I was on air when this happened
before and it was pretty shocking
for everybody there obviously people
watching on television it was designed
to shock it was designed to get our
attention first of all what was your
reaction when you saw this
well annoyance obviously you could
imagine I've got paying customers normal
working class people that have saved up
to get a ticket by the way in The
Crucible to watch this Luke is not easy
sales out already next year's already
sold out these people have been lucky
enough they've got a ticket they're in
place ready to enjoy their special
moment and it was spoiled by someone my
secondary thought really was this is
nothing to do with just stop oil
because it didn't do their calls any
good at all in fact it was the opposite
I think it damaged their calls it made
me want to go and buy oil well it made
me not want to give anything I you know
as individuals we give to lots of
different charities or different there's
no way they may well have a case by the
way ecologically speaking but by doing
that I think they cheapen themselves
into sort of the bully boys of sport
because sport is such an easy target
people you know you can't I mean I
believe in security I think we've got
good security we have for 40. but I
don't see I don't see why wrecking the
fun for ordinary people
coming up to go to this how does that
big annual event how does that put
across their point the answer is it
doesn't at all if anything it's a huge
negative to them and working-class
people and ordinary people everywhere in
the world would look on that with
disdain and they wouldn't look at it and
say well let's look into this just stop
oil principle they look at it and saw a
rich kid getting some attention by doing
something that's actually really easy to
do it's been a bully boy tactics they
bought a ticket I think they paid 300
quid for their ticket they bought a top
class ticket with all the trimmings and
went out and spot everyone's enjoyment
for the night you're now going to sue
just stop oil activist edrid Whittingham
who was the guy we saw there tell me
about that well it's interesting because
I was frustrated I mean I was frustrated
when I spent two and a half hours on the
M25 in a junction that's another time
another story but the same principle
applies it's putting Ordinary People you
know out of pocket or out of place
I'm frustrated about what can I do do I
make the whole place into a fortress of
security and take away that very special
atmosphere that existed Crucible I don't
want to do that it's never been
necessary before I've had two streakers
we got rid of them quite quickly but
they weren't the same they were just
extroverts here we've got a situation
where we sat down as a group and said
why don't we do do we tighten security
do we make it a really body search
everybody coming is that What sport's
really about now my book says no so I'm
trying to think how I can be you know
constructive in how we can deal with it
and we come up with this idea of the
small claims court because we thought
well you know all these people have
spent their money on a ticket on their
hotels on their travel maybe babysitters
whatever so I wrote to the 410 people
that witnessed that and lost their table
that they were supposed to be watching
and said look I believe you've got a
claim we will help you we will help you
formulate this let's take this little
boy this attention-seeking little boy
let's ruin his life let's take into the
small claims court as many times as
possible I wrote to 410 people 64 have
come back and said yes we'd like to be
part of this so now our lawyers are
working with them and saying how do we
help you 64 different cases in the small
claims court where he will be expected I
like an appearance I like this because
this will really get to the heart of
these people yes if they actually have
to suffer that kind of sacrifice yeah
they might think twice about the way
they protest I've got no problem in
people doing normal peaceful protein
none at all when they when they
deliberately wreck things which other
people are enjoying or they're stopping
people going to work or whatever they
lose me they're not putting a point
across they are just disruptive for
disruption's sake they're attention
Seekers that are not actually saying
believe in this we have a system in this
country it's called democracy it's not
Anarchy this is a democracy and there
are ways of putting your point across
they chose to ignore it and we have to
take action I see the protesters at the
Dartford Tunnel got three and a half
years and two and a half years that's
another one I'm thoroughly in favor of
yeah you know I was in a traffic jam for
two and a half hours next to an
ambulance trying to get it's outrageous
you know a woman three cars away was in
tears because she she missed her
father's funeral disgusting you know so
what do you do you can't just stand back
in our small way we thought let's just
disrupt his life as much as he's
disrupted others and there are 64
letters going out in a perfectly
peaceful manner he's just gonna get a
load of uh Ritz and it will cost him a
load of money hopefully I don't really
care about the money I want to give him
some inconvenience yes quite right uh I
could talk to you all night just give me
one little thing my team Arsenal yeah
choked in my opinion the Premier League
there were eight points clear 8.8 games
to go
do you agree with me no no look I've had
night I had 19 years as chairman of late
Nora and I know all about football not
your level your expectation level was
lower well that's the problem isn't it
and you're judging it on expectation
level rather than reality the reality is
their professional Sportsman they're
trying to win and they're proud is it
fair that Manchester City have all this
oil money which allows them to have a
grotesque Financial advice again over
everybody else there's 123 claims
against them for them to justify and
fight this Saga will run longer than
Agatha Christie's the mouse trap it's
going to go on forever but at the end of
the day Arsenal and I know you don't
want this because you're through blue
and Arsenal at the end of the day they
weren't quite good enough you see I
don't agree I just said they were
mentally strong enough they didn't
believe that may be part of being not
quite good enough they needed to be more
like Michael block
they needed to believe they belonged on
the top stage they've got to do it over
40 odd games throughout the season in
front of a very good wherever the monies
come from will be an issue answered
later but for the moment hats off to
Manchester City they are one of the
greats of my lifetime they are very good
team all right great to see you always a
pleasure miles uh peace it's Miles and
Miles where are we going I actually
haven't made good miles to be pleased
about that you're thinking talking about
him good to see you thanks mate Eddie
I'm censored next a war on Free Speech
in the name of Professor Kathleen stock
is taking over Oxford University and
couldn't see the end of this famed
debating Club isn't hearing opposing
viewpoints the entire point of debate
will be debating the lack of debate at
Oxford next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what about one
two
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Facebook and uncensored
Professor Kathleen stock a student
speaker Oxford University's 200 year old
Tibetan Society next month but she's
faced a furious backlash from students
who say her supposedly transphobic views
means she shouldn't be given a platform
which is the same academic you had to
quit her job as a lecturer at the
University of Sussex after being
targeted by activists for her views on
gender identity Oxford University's Vice
chancellor has defend his stocks
appearance as a matter of Free Speech
but the university is braced for up to a
thousand protesters and counter
protesters to take action when she
appears at the end of the month the
Student Union is understood to have cut
ties with the debate and Society so
there's a huge Rift now at the heart of
Oxford University it all begs the
question how exactly are supposed to
have a debating Society if you don't
actually allow proper debate with people
whose opinions you don't like well join
me now is podcast host a comedian
Constantine kissing professor of
Sociology at Oxford University Dr
Michael Briggs and Oxford student and
trans right activist who is Posner well
welcome to all of you uh rizz you're
over there in Oxford
um let me start with you you've been on
the show before
um I don't get this the whole point of
getting universities you're supposed to
have open minds hear views you may not
like challenge manage them put your own
views forward evolve learn
um what's all this censorship about
yeah I mean effectively this is students
exercising their own free speech right
like she has been platformed by this
institution students have consistently
said we don't think she should speak
here we don't want her here because her
views are part of a a broader hate
campaign and moral Panic that's really
damaging the lives of trans people so
students students have
large institutions in the student union
and now the University have overruled
that vote I also want to clarify
something here The Su the Student Union
voted to cut ties with the debating
Society the Oxford Union not over this
but over an extensive history of them
um bullying harassing and just having
like General bigotry racism within their
within their institution so it's not
over this nuanced issue it's about the
history of the but on the specific point
about Kathleen stock you tweeted this
you've got some Effie nerve Kathleen
you've brought your hatred into our
community and now you use the threats we
receive because of your actions to try
to Garner more sympathy for your victim
narrative Oxford doesn't want your
bigotry here and will make it known now
I've studied the Kathleen stock Saga I
actually come from Sussex so I had a
vested interest in my county and this
University what is it about her that is
so hateful what has she said or done
that is actually so Wicked
yeah Kathleen has consistently uh well
so what she does is she's a academic
front basically for this broader
movement which she has uh endorsed she's
endorsed Posey Parker who has said
horrific things that I don't think would
be appropriate what is Kathleen's stock
hang on what is Kathleen stock herself
said or done to Warrant this treatment
yeah I don't know yeah I understand I
don't know if you've read her book first
you consistently misgenders people she
talks about whether like trans ideology
should exist whether trans people should
be part of the lgbtq community
um now
her what she talks about is is part of a
massive campaign against trans people
and she wasn't kicked out of Warwick
University she left because she was
bummed that people didn't like what she
had to say because okay
can I just yeah
here's my point
you see I have looked at what she said
she says many trans women are still
males with male genitalia many are
sexually attracted to females they
should not be in places where females
undress or sleep in an unrestricted way
self ID threatens a secure understanding
of the concept of lesbian and so on she
stands up for the sanctity of biological
sex
and I'm struggling to find out what is
so offensive about all this it seems to
me what's more offensive are young
students who think the biological sex is
a Movable Feast that can be denied and
that's the science is to be ignored and
that anyone can put their hand up and
say they're anything they like and they
have to be respected that I find more
offensive than anything Kathleen stock
has said
so that's absolutely fine if you find
that offensive because the reality is as
much as she exercises her right to free
speech so do we the students have
consistently said as I've mentioned
before that they don't welcome her hair
and specifically the tweet that you
quoted me honoring free speeches that's
the opposite of free speech Yes what
you're doing is
opinions you don't agree with my
argument is I agree with a lot of what
she says I don't get it what you're
doing is your business
as a group you're behaving like a bunch
of young fascists you want people only
people so who toe the line to your world
view and her worldview by the way could
you just let me know when I can come
back to those points all right
now let me come through okay Constantine
this strikes me as right to the heart of
the malaise and our Academia worldwide
actually this world view I don't like
this person's views even though they're
not that controversial at all in fact
most people would agree with them and
yet they have to be de-platformed abused
Brandy bigots blah blah blah this right
here is the heart of this of this
problem and let me answer the question
that Riz didn't answer when you asked
her what Kathleen has done that is so
wrong is she's blasphemed against this
new religion that says trans women are
women and as you say the vast majority
of the public don't agree with that and
therefore students have to then become
little fascist like you said and shut
this down because they can't tolerate
hearing and opinion that they don't like
and so to the extent that they have
power they're going to use it to bully
people into not speaking in places that
they can I'm grateful that the
government pushed through the the bill
which now means universities have to
ensure that free speech is respected
there it's very very important that
these people don't win because you can
see their smug faces as they do this and
and they enjoy the power and they enjoy
exercising over people and by the way
I've interviewed Kathleen on my show
trigonometry she's one of the sweetest
kindest more generous gentle people that
you will meet if she's hate well then
we're all hateful well this is the point
isn't it um
question what is going on there because
a lot of a lot of the academic people
there now seem to be rising up against
this and supporting the concept of Free
Speech but that's causing a rift now in
the University what's really going on
well I think it's good that things have
come to a head and we finally can debate
about whether whether we could listen to
the very mild as constant density the
very mild views of Kathleen stock which
really represents the uh the majority of
British people now maybe not not the
majority of students but even the
minority of students have a right to
hear if they should uh they want to hear
Kathleen Stock's views and even people
who are opposed to her like like Riz
should go along out of the and and
listen and just decide what why exactly
what they disagree with what this whole
concept when I've when I've taken part
in the Oxford Union which I've done and
the Cambridge Union and others I've
always enjoyed it but I've always gone
there believing it was my job to try and
make people come around to my way of
thinking which was an old debate I
thought I was back at my old prep school
for the first time in 50 odd years uh
the other day at the weekend and I
passed this old white house where the
head Masters wife used to hold debating
society when I was about seven or eight
and that we were encouraged at that age
challenge other views listen to other
views formulate your own opinion and be
unafraid to change it if you hear things
which change your mind this is all just
gone out the window
so the problem is if you have a certain
Identity or if you have a certain view
then you can say I'm so vulnerable uh I
can't listen to any opposing views that
they even even now I kind of not listen
but even the very existence of those
other views being articulated somewhere
you know within the within a five mile
radius Catherine stock said anything
that you see which would justify this
kind of treatment no of course not no PS
just to the point you made about you
when you go and when I went to the
Oxford Union about trying to persuade
people and think about what would be the
circumstances in which you wouldn't want
to persuade people and you would want to
shut down people who disagree with you
the only circumstance in which you might
be tempted to do that is if you know
your arguments are rubbish yeah and that
is why these people or if you're living
in Russia China or North Korea right
where you would then call the secret
police and they would come and remove
the person with the offensive opinion
which was one that the government didn't
agree with or whatever and they would be
taken off to some Detention Center in
Siberia I mean this is this is where
we're heading this is what they don't
get these students is that once you
accept that you're allowed to do this to
people who are perfectly mainstream
opinions this is a slippery slope to do
to totalitarianism right quiet
Riz we've can I respond to that you can
respond to that you're a totalitarian
Barbarian
so you've talked about uh fascism
fascism as a far right ideology about
suppressing stuff uh to be clear this
has been a consistent Democratic uh
students have made this together at that
point do you object to being called
right wing
yeah yeah absolutely I already mentioned
that because when we invited uh the
president of Oxford University lgbtq
plus Society to come on the program he
replied I think he's a he
um this is Adi haran dimmer do you know
do you know that person
uh yeah and I'd actually like to talk
about that that person did not come on
your show because they have been subject
to this consistent profit
that I've been talking about finish this
point hang on I'm going to finish my
point well
that wasn't the reason given by this
person who replied higher to my producer
nice to meet you we're reluctant to work
with right-wing media so I'm not right
wing I've never been right wing uh
you're not right you object to being
called right wing I object to being cool
right wing so we found a point of
consensus
so the reason that uh other people don't
want to uh take up interviews like this
or be on platforms like this is because
of the hate campaigns
at least you have the gun should I just
respond to some of those points peers
well look thank you I was actually
paying you I was paying you a compliment
you do at least come on and debate with
me right yeah
because they don't want to hear someone
saying something they don't like
I'd really love to respond to that point
so you mentioned uh that the tweet that
I said in response to Kathleen now what
you didn't mention is that Kathleen was
responding to a tweet by Addie who you
previously mentioned uh publishing a
death threat that they received by one
of her fans that's why people don't want
to be on platforms like this now with
regards to a debate uh first of all I
don't believe that trans lives should be
a debate but that's not in question here
give me a fabulous conversation before
no one's debating trans lives no one was
debating trans rights to fairness and
equality I've certainly never did I've
only ever supported trans rights to
fairness equality but if you're gonna
stand there now on television and and
say that you believe what's happening in
women's sport for example is anything
but grotesquely unfair and unequal then
say so if you genuinely believe it I
think what's grotesquely unfair and
unequal is the violence and hatred that
trans people are consistently facing in
the media in person in public and online
as well
wasn't my question is it fair that trans
athletes are now demolishing women born
with female biological bodies at women's
sport is that fair yes or no
this is a really boring point but I'm
happy to answer just give me a simple
yes or no that's not happening
all right absolutely okay it's not
happening you're obviously not reading
the papers you're not watching TV you
are totally oblivious to the reality of
what's happening but I didn't realize
okay it's okay no problem ignorance is
bliss right good to see you thank you
very much um
I mean again because it's the mindset
doesn't even it wouldn't even consider
the possibility that what's happening in
sport and women's sport is it is
horrible because she has no idea has no
interest only interested in the impact
it's a religion Pierce I've said this to
you before I'll say it again it's a
religious worldview whereby your beliefs
do not require evidence they're based on
a faith right and that's how these
people think so uh the reason I
mentioned the
Kathleen stock what she's doing as all
of us are doing is right because she
thinks she's entitled to call this this
woman Kathy's talk a bigot and so on and
so on um I want to just quickly ask you
about something else because you're a
comedian
John Cleese is warned that his life of
Brian's stage show based on the movie
shouldn't include a scene about a man
wanting to be a woman and having a baby
which is ironic given the subject matter
we've been discussing let's take a look
at the famous clip why are you always on
about women's Stan
I want to be one would you oppress me
it was funny at the time it's kind of
ironic now
uh but he even John Cleese
feels compelled to perhaps remove that
because it may offend people the concept
of men of a joke about men having babies
but we reached a point where yeah there
will be protests about that because it's
offensive isn't it amazing because it
looks like they're literally quoting
from 2023 conversations in the satirical
piece of satire becoming real life and
what it shows you I think most of all
how far we've come in this delusion I
totally agree because actually those
degrees I mean that was deemed to be
humor at the time because it was so
ludicrous that nobody ever assumed that
would actually be a reality but we've
reached that point where satire's coming
true yes yes indeed but I think though
just to take up the point about the the
religion I mean the reason why there's
so much hate towards uh Kathleen stock
is because she's a lesbian yeah because
she's an apostate so she's part of the
LGBT community but she's uh she's
articulating a different View and so
therefore she has to be she's much more
threatening than than most people would
be I saw a community called Freddie
Quinn on morning TV Good Morning Britain
today and he made the point there's a
scene from that movie with a guy with a
lisp does that have to go because it's
offensive to people's speech impediments
there's a scene with a character called
incontinentia buttocks is that offensive
to people with IBS it's the same with
people with big noses is that offensive
to people with big noses there's one
about blessing the cheese makers do we
have to reach out to a National
Association of Dairy Farmers to see if
they're upset by it and the truth is
actually probably yes because somebody
somewhere would be already getting the
pitchforks out ready to blow their
gasket about all these scenes being
offensive until eventually there is no
Life of Brian that and that's why I
think all of us have to just ignore
these people being silly which is what
they're doing and say you're allowed to
be offended nothing happens when you get
offended nothing changes and the world
does not start revolving what Ricky
Gervais always says yeah he has a right
to say what he says you have a right to
be offended your right to be offended
doesn't over overcome his own right to
crack jokes uh thank you both very much
indeed I appreciate next to London
theater hops on the U.S Trend but
dedicating performances to black only
audiences in those blackout nights is
that empowering or segregating that
debate is next
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
thank you
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
laughs
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
foreign
theater Land and the UK and the US
blackout performances are dedicated to
black only audiences those who are not
black are asked not to buy tickets the
theater of Royal Stratford East in
London says no one's excluded from
attending their new show Tambo and Bones
promotional material makes clear that
white people aren't wanted the
production on the 19 questions as a
blackout night is a purposeful creation
of an environment in which an all black
identifying audience like identified
audience can experience and discuss an
event in Performing Arts free from the
white gays does this mean I can go if I
identify as a black man there'll be some
on the woke side who would have
well that trouble disagreeing with that
given they believe in Limitless
self-identity but it is more importantly
is it ever okay to exclude audiences
based on skin color what would happen
for example if it was all the way around
if this was a white only audience well
I'm joined by the talk TV contributor
Esther Krakow and the black lives matter
organizer and activist Iman Aiden all
right Imam I'm just trying to picture
what would happen if I put on a
theatrical production in London and it
said it was for whites only
or people identifying as white which is
obviously a ludicrous phrase but
you would go nuts you would say that is
blatant racism segregation dragged us
Kicking and Screaming back to the dark
days of appalling bigotry you would
depends on the context right there's no
why it's only audience yes it depends no
black people allowed what would you say
well I think you're perfectly right it
would be akin to racist finding more
ways to be more racist so why is it okay
this way around okay so we have to put
it into context it was one out of the 29
shows doesn't matter yes it does let's
put it into context pairs you want to
forget about context context is
everything it is one out of the 29 shows
that will talk is it towards black
people and at no point did they say
people certain people are not excluded
in fact they actually sell it they beat
them on their website no one is excluded
and yet you have found racism no no I
just read the rest of what they said
it's pretty clear you are not supposed
to go if you're not black no please
consider booking other dates right
exactly I think I think the context
you're right the context is important I
think the issue here is when it when
it's talking about sort of you know
blackouts and it's trying to gather an
audience of black people that they
believe have the same experience this
doesn't transpose the same way it does
in the US and the UK right a black
person in the UK could be black African
uh black British or you know black from
the Caribbean right in the US their
conversation around race is completely
different and that's why it's a problem
obviously when you bring this to the UK
people are going to be like what are you
talking about this is especially in
London can you see any Merit can you see
any Merit to it of course of course but
that's an
inner spaces because let's just be clear
we're talking about say space
what does that mean because okay so you
want to feel safe if I came along no no
again context we're talking about a play
that was done by black people for black
people targeted for black people and so
one out of the again let's just be clear
because you're clearly not getting this
message it is basically akin to the
disabled Community putting on putting on
29 shows and one oh 29 shows about
disabilities and then one of those shows
is targeted towards the disabled
community that is what it is akin to and
yet you have a problem why is that this
have you genuinely asked yourself I have
a problem between disabilities
but when it comes to Black my problem is
that you have already conceded that if
it was the other way around and this was
a whites only night of this theatrical
you would say racist and that's my
problems
unfortunately affected by racism so
therefore it's about safe spaces this
place
the idea of safe spaces and black people
needing to leave safe space
let's talk about racism
do Asian people need safe spaces
no she just asked me a question so I'm
answering it we're talking about Asian
racism I think they deserve a bit of a
safe space when they're talking about
their own experiences
from all types of people that are going
to all right judgments because it's
about being free of judgments
free of Asian judgments that somebody
else speaks please no I'm going to we're
going to have a safe space where you get
removed so the only I can be heard
speaking and I'll say bye to you both I
will have a one night only only tears
happily I'll see you on Saturday I'll
say bye one night or so only I am
allowed to speak and you're not allowed
to because of your skin color how would
you like that well that's called racism
exactly exactly my point no it's not let
me ask you this What would most black
friends of yours or family think about
this I mean in other words is it
something where a lot of black people
might know what actually I can see some
Merit to this they would see it as an
American importation right I don't mean
necessarily a bad thing I think that it
would no yeah it would be seen it would
be seen as ridiculous but ridiculously
particularly American right because they
black people are not a monolith which we
can all agree on black people come from
various parts of the world they have
different cultures this idea that there
is a shared black experience
other than the color of our skin but I
don't but you have you you have to
accept there are many connotations
you're adding by your own I could say
this I could say that as a black person
I faced more racism from Asian and
Middle Eastern people so I should have a
safe space from those people can you
even identify them no but that's because
that's ridiculous I don't think okay let
me interrupt actually I don't think any
form of art should ever be exclusionary
on the grounds of skin color regardless
of who it's targeted to or who it's made
by talking about racism the whole point
of art is it should be for everybody
we're talking about race equity for
everybody no no contacts I don't know
it's not right it's not racially equal
about this yes it's racially unequal
you're saying no white people can come
it's ridiculous what's the play about
this I've heard you're right what's the
plan it doesn't matter what it's about
it does it doesn't it's your issue you
want to negate context and there is no
it doesn't matter if both of us without
context you know this and yet you try to
negotiate no I don't know this no you
don't remember the context don't come
with it with the context you can't tell
me what I'm thinking exactly
what people like you do to me people
like me yes
racially Prejudice people like yourself
that's what you do that's why we need
safe spaces you're calling me racially
prejudiced I've done that several times
first why are you surprised why are you
saying that ignorance doesn't actually
suit you that's ignorant actually what
you just said I've just told you I'm not
racially Prejudiced and what you just
said was very offensive shouldn't be
saying that pierce what's present yes
huh what's Prejudice if you're racist
prejudiced you are a racist that's what
you just called I'm not accepting that
sorry it's Prejudice um Esther will you
go and watch
that's what you do we're gonna leave it
there thank you both very much I
appreciate it and since the next after
can on a Johnny Depp with a standing
ovation his Hollywood's dead boycott now
over here's back is next
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one two
[Music]
thank you
and coming up on the talk a London
theater is accused of setting a
dangerous precedent after warning white
patrons to stay away from a new play
plus it has speeding Sue Ella run out of
Road the Home Secretary claims innocence
over reports she asked civil servants to
arrange a private penalty course and
find out why a 7 to 12 year age Gap is
being hailed The Sweet Spot for
successful marriages that's all coming
up at nine
thank you
welcome back to Facebook I'm joined by
the former conservative MP which is
Mensch and the associate material mirror
Kevin McGuire what a stellar little duo
we have here so a survey came out Kevin
I'm going to ask you first because I was
your boss one you were the narcissists
make the best bosses they'll be very
careful how you answer this I remember
about a decade ago the guardian got a
neuroscience writer to run the rule over
you and decide if you were an officer
and didn't you admit actually did you
admit in your interview with am I wrong
I did that you are I do think I have
slight narcissistic streaks I don't
think I'm fully but I think I'm
self-aware now yeah I think I think you
were like a brilliant and a terrible
boss which day it was if only anything's
really safe I was easily pleased and
easily annoyed I think Louise I mean
you've had a few bosses in your time I
have on our narcissist actually do they
have the skill set for being bosses do
you think well I think they do and I've
had a bit of an unusual career so my
bosses have been either Prime Ministers
or rock stars so I don't think I've got
any non-narcissistic bosses to compare
it to but if you've just got a slight
Touch of narcissism then you're a good
leader you strike out you try new things
a bit of the Elon Musk about yes you
know you have New Zealand musk and
narcissist probably a little bit I did
but in but he's also doing a lot of
stuff that's really interesting and good
for the planet right I mean it goes It
goes along with the territory a lot of
things are a clinical narcissist but
he's got self belief I mean he's driven
but then you see him all over the place
on Twitter yeah uh and it's not working
at the moment it might in the end I
think I think you can you can be a touch
of a narcissist but if you're a total
narcissist and you won't listen to
anybody who's given sensible
constructive uh advice and support then
I think you've become a bad boss I want
to play a clip of someone it might well
be analysis it's Johnny Depp a lot of
opinion about him this is him talking in
can about being boycotted by Hollywood
do I feel boycotted now no
not at all I don't feel boycotted by
Hollywood because I don't think about it
I don't think about Hollywood I don't uh
I don't have much further need for
Hollywood myself everybody
would love to be able to be themselves
but they can't
because they must fall in line
with the person in front of them
I mean Louise he's got a point I mean we
are living in society where I went to
the Chelsea flash today I must have had
a dozen people come up to me saying you
you speak for us right we're just none
of us are able to say what you say now I
was really struck by the number of
people on that one thing Free Speech the
ability to speak absolutely and the
whole trans debates that we're talking
about elsewhere is part and parcel of
this and can you really blame Johnny
Depp for saying look I'm incredibly Rich
I'm incredibly famous I've got all the
awards maybe he just wants to let it go
he doesn't want to follow the Hollywood
set path and say all the nice polite
things and maybe he wants to let his
middle age spread fly you know we're
talking about
Awards in middle age spread letting
things fly here is our YouTube award for
Piers Morgan on censored passing a
million subscribers that's impressive in
one year which makes this the fastest
growing show in the country in terms of
a new YouTube channel so thank you very
much for following us there we have a
lot of people watching on on YouTube
yeah which is the new the need place to
go what do you think what's the answer
with this free speech debate and when
you hear students like that girl I just
I shouldn't even identify as a girl
she's they them
um I don't know what the answer is when
they just are so entrenched are they
hearing other views but the truth is
this debate is as old as speech itself
it it's it's not new we're more aware of
it now because of social media and
people can have platforms and they
either use them themselves try to shout
others down say they should be canceled
but I remember the right wing in the
1980s trying to cancel anyone who was
consistent yeah but oddly Looney left
oddly the won't left have become the new
fascists their mindset
like I'm on the left but uh you're not
I'm a liberal no no no I think you've
got to engage with people and respect
respect uh other opinions have a robust
don't worry there you go I want a quick
prediction U.S president and the next UK
prime minister after both elections give
me two names right it's gonna be Joe
Biden if it's Donald Trump opposing him
and it's I regret to say it's going to
be kirst armor as the next prime
minister with a bit more of a smile and
Joe Biden I here's I'm going to say
rushy soon I can run DeSantis is the
outside bet but not impossible yeah
we're gonna we're gonna clip now to play
back right yeah yeah on the YouTube
channel I'm gonna leave it there
remember follow us on YouTube it's all
there join the million whatever you're
up to Keep It Uncensored Keep It
Uncensored
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
thank you
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable